sometimes they just feel like nothing I
do matters I got no special we only got
one retweet today from your mom sad we
were just wondering if maybe you could
give our broader shout out a shout out
from me would be a little off-brand
fifteen thousand followers you know what
that means beauty like this
more to the left is hearts more to it
really hope nothing bad happening to it
he vanished right anybody who could be
next
even you you can find more information
by our tragedy girls Twitter page your
brains my car's blown into anything
are you afraid that the killer will
target even because if you're into this
blog we will not take any more [ __ ] from
this serial killer I'm so scared right
now look
Mikaela okay sorry
stay in character phones oh it's a
matter of life and death
do you remember our first time
thanks for the tragedy girls
[Music]
nothing heavy flow day I don't know if
that's not how that works right now it's
important to distinguish with what kind
of killers we're talking about here
serial killers can operate over many
weeks and have very distinct patterns
when selecting their victim wild spree
killers don't have cooling-off periods
and kill like two or more people in a
short amount of time so it's like a
Jeffrey Dahmer versus a Charles
Starkweather but what kind of killer is
operating in Rosedale right now and more
importantly is he behind the
disappearance of bridges and even
[Music]
hi mr. Cunningham uh it's here to pick
up Sadie I George Jordan Jordan Welsh
we've met a couple times my dad's the
sheriff one time in middle school you
told me he liked to stay away from my
daughter
I'm here I'm here for prom
Sadie if we get a picture real quick
okay there you go you gotta tap the
screen it's just a little tapping the
screen
that's right there's in the fridge pop
thanks sweetheart you're home safe
[Music]
you